all right uh hello everyone
uh welcome to the second day of talks
about the robust speech recognition
challenge uh hosted by hugging face so
today's first talk is uh will be given
by gabriel who is the data engineer
working on commonwise
hugging face so today's first talk is
in the mozilla
research team and the talk is going to
be about unlocking global speech with
the mozilla
uh
commonwealth
and during the talk if you have any
questions or feel free to post it in the
comments and we'll uh try to answer
those questions at the end of the talk
so uh take it away gabriel
yeah hey
hello everyone uh thanks for the
introduction uh as previously mentioned
before my name is gabriel and i am a
software developer on the common voice
team for the mozilla foundation and
today's talk is all about the project
common voice
starting with some background and
history as well as diving into the
problems that we're looking to solve and
then generally how the platform works
and how you can engage with the data
sets as they're released
so uh just to kick things off uh just
some context about myself anyway is i
joined the team not too long ago so if i
misspeak or unable to answer any
questions i apologize in advance and
with that being said all hope is not
lost as the common voice has a fantastic
community and can be easily engaged with
at the discourse as you see here the
communication port
of the slide
and as well as that as uh
as it is open source the
code and technical documentation is all
available online at github common voice
and the specific application itself the
common voice application is available as
well
and even beyond that you can actually
use the platform
and access it online at
commonvoice.mozilla.org so feel free to
engage
in all those
ways with the team and myself
so let's just quickly take a step back
and talk about the goals of the
foundation in and of itself and how that
relates to the common voice project so
uh the foundation uh is all geared up to
ensure the
ensure that the internet remains as
public as possible and open to all
essentially
to summarize what the quote is and how
the common voice engages with that in
particular is through building
trustworthy ai and enabling open data
sets
so let's talk about the problem at hand
and what we're looking to solve with
common voice
specifically the problem relates to
technologies that leverage ai models and
the inherent biases that they uh are
trained with so simply put if a data set
doesn't have representation of diverse
groups uh the models will not perform
well for set groups it kind of makes
sense that way
uh and speech technology in particular
is no exception
the performance of automatic speech
recognition is often poor for less
represented groups and this problem has
become more and more visible as the use
of voice-operated devices continues to
grow around the globe
people whose speech patterns differ from
societal norms find that their devices
you know just do not understand them
particularly well or even worse yet
their languages aren't supported at all
some examples of this can be seen in
some english language training sets
which
may skew heavily into direction towards
male demographics as is seen in google
speech recognition software which is 13
more accurate for men than for women
so with all that being said what is
common voice and how does it aim to
solve helps up with problems
well let's just
uh get some context first into the
project and how it was formed uh it
originally started in 2017 and it was
launched in a completely english only uh
as a as a completely english-only data
set
and helped power deep speech
from then its populated popularity grew
and so did its language set which
included uh
german irish and many others uh as it
continued to grow forward
uh and that's been fantastic then there
was a restructure at mozilla itself and
then that's how the mozilla foundation
kind of took ownership of the project
and as a result of that uh to today
we've you know grown the project even
more and
with help of many partners around the
globe uh we continue to hope to grow the
project
so how does it all come together in the
real world like how do we actually
create data sets and power this
application uh well it really comes from
uh the countless volunteers that donate
their time and voice to the project uh
generally said if a
member of the community wants to add uh
language to the platform there's a
little bit of a procedure for them to
follow and that includes uh obviously
making the request as well as then
facilitating uh translation of the
website into that language because
obviously people who speak the language
would like to interact with our platform
in their native language it makes sense
and then after collecting enough open
sentences for people to read uh that new
language will launch into the platform
and then we'll welcome other volunteers
to donate their time and their uh
voices to help facilitate
click generation and after all that on a
quarterly release cycle we transformed
the raw data
by cleaning and
anonymizing some of the data and then
release it publicly to the
to the world to use
now let's uh quickly walk through the
platform itself and give you guys a
better understanding of how exactly this
comes to be
so
to start off with we give people an
option uh to sign up and create a
profile and then attach certain metadata
to the profile that will be attached to
the clips that they're validating and
speaking however this is completely
optional you do not need an account to
get started
uh the main component of the application
is the ability to donate your voice by
reading uh sentences that are given to
you and then
having those
clips validated by other community
members and you can contribute either
either which way or both or however you
want so you don't even need a microphone
to actually help the platform you could
start by validating clips and as you
grow more comfortable you could actually
donate your voice as well
and then
uh the whole purpose of the the platform
in and of itself is to allow
and build open data sets for other
organizations to implement and use in
their speech technologies so of course
we offer that ability to download the
the data and it's it's available under a
cc-0 license so pretty accessible and
there's just a few little like privacy
check marks you have to sign saying like
you don't want to expose people's
identities and stuff like that but all
in all it's very uh open for you to use
uh however which way you like
so let's talk about the data set
specifically uh after downloading the
data you'll
realize there's a lot of information
associated with the clips and generally
that
it's organized in tsp files uh
so the tsp files hold all the metadata
surrounding the clips and there we
separated the contents of clips into
these files based on a certain criteria
of if it's valid if it's been validated
if it's been invalidated and if we don't
really know exactly where uh it sits in
uh in that in that sphere
so generally uh the validated uh list
contains clips that have received more
than two
validations and have more valid upvotes
than downloads so people in the
community have generally regarded it as
a valid clip whereas invalidated tsp
files contain rows of clips that have
been
generally
engaged with with downloads people don't
really
agree with the clip representing the
sentence that it's supposed to read
okay
so that was a quick uh hot take of the
data sets in and of itself but uh we're
actually on the precipice of releasing
the next data set of version eight and
it's looking like a great one uh to
speak candidly
uh it'll have over 18 000 hours of voice
data which is pretty fantastic and it
has over 450 000
uh people and volunteers who have both
recorded and validated clips so it's a
truly international global effort that
uh this even exists
so obviously uh we'd like to take a step
back and look at the impact of our of
our data sets and how it's impacted the
real world and uh
what good it's been able to accomplish
one quick example uh recently has been
the adoption of the rwanda community's
use of uh common voice data to power a
covey tool that allows individuals to
interact with the platform using their
native languages as well as french and
english english
and from an academic standpoint uh we
continue to see use of our data sets uh
throughout academia and corporate
research
and then looking forward into the future
of common voice because i mean
you also have to look forward to the
future um
we're actually experimenting and looking
to adapt more uh customizable accents
and variants for clips so
not every speaker can fall into one
category of accent and we want to really
diversify the actions and then also give
more context for each clip
as well as the actual data set
enhancements themselves uh one of the
things i would like to call out as well
is the increased frequency of data being
released so ideally we're going to start
pushing out more and more data releases
yearly which will allow people to engage
with the data
much fresher data that is
and generally uh the goals for the
foundation are even more broad and that
we truly want to engage with the
community in multiple different avenues
including you know
uh enabling organizations to use the
data sets to
incorporating more diverse data sets etc
etc
and yeah that was uh my quick
take on
the common voice team and uh where we're
at right now and i
hope that you all enjoyed the talk was
very quick again and there's a lot more
to be learned again on the platform
itself at our github and discourse and
if you're feeling uh motivated please
feel free to contribute back to the
platform by donating your voice or even
just validating some clips
so yeah thanks for your time and thanks
for listening
all right uh thank you very much for the
great job gabrielle
we have a question so
dan is asking will danish be included in
the commonwealth 8 data set
and
i would have to double check to see if
the specific language is being included
uh i haven't done so though so i can't
say yes or no right now
okay
you don't have any more you'll be able
to
see the data set released sometime next
week
okay
now if you have any other questions feel
free to post those in the chats
and if you uh don't have questions now
but come up with questions later feel
free to again engage with us on our
discourse
okay there's a question from uh patrick
uh patrick is asking does common voice
analyzes somehow how biased a language
is example male versus female speakers
well i don't think we as like a platform
uh
skew the data being released in any
capacity like that but we provide the
metadata associated with eclipse that
allows people using the data to analyze
for gender or age for example if it's
available on the clip so thus you could
kind of tell which which way it's skewed
i
suppose uh there's another question is
there a demo for using a pi torch module
such as back to vector
uh yes jonathan i think you can find one
on the hugging face hub on on on the
spaces i'm sure
there's going to be at least one uh one
such demo
all right the
next question is uh is there any overlap
between commonwealth versions
so do you mean like uh the data sets
being backwards compatible i suppose
uh i don't think there's any guarantee
that the major versions between common
voice releases are backwards compatible
but generally i think there are release
notes that are associated if if that is
the case or otherwise
okay thank you
the next question is from felix and
felix is asking how are the accents
going to be better represented in the
future
and what efforts are made there
so we've actually enabled the ability
for individuals to add their own accents
so that we don't have to quantify or
qualify what accents there are and
really allow the community to drive uh
what they think makes sense about their
specific language so the idea is that
any individual can can
confidently say that i belong to one
accent and then let the community as a
whole pick up on that
okay and
the next question is how do you select
the sentences to read that's a fantastic
question so there is a whole
platform side of things where
there's two kind of avenues for sentence
selecting
uh one is we engage with partners that
allow us to
pull in open source sentences that we
can add to our platform and have uh
people read and validate so for example
wikipedia
articles and and such
otherwise they're added individually by
contributors who've you know ensured
that the sentences that they're adding
are you know appropriate and open source
but also they can contribute
individually
okay there's a
follow-up question is it possible to
suggest some sentences
yes i do believe that through the
sentence platform uh you can actually
suggest
be added to the corpus
okay nice uh we have two more questions
so uh dan is asking uh do you have plans
to include dialects as well uh rather
than only accents
that's a good question i'm not too
certain if that's been explored just yet
the ability to add dialects but i think
that's something we could definitely
think about in the future
thank you and
patrick is asking
how do you know that a sample that has
been apported twice is actually of a
good quality
yeah so that's a general heuristic we've
added to help validate the
the clips themselves i mean obviously
it's not a perfect science and there
could be
um
you know an anomaly where multiple
people validate a bad clip but that's a
result of uh you know open source data
sets like this and platforms like this
it all kind of revolves around the
quality and
strength of the open source community at
large
okay
oh we have another question
uh julian is asking how do you decide or
prioritize new languages and anything we
can do to help you have as many
contributors as possible
yeah so actually a lot of the
idea of like bringing in new languages
to the platform comes from the community
itself and
us in the foundation don't really have
too much say in it so if it's a
community driven
addition then it's likely to succeed by
you naturally over time gathering uh
supporters and contributors to that
language
and as for like adding or helping by
um have as many contributors as possible
i mean just engaging with the platform
engaging with the discourse and
community at large as well as obviously
you know sharing on social media that
you're taking part of this platform and
such
all goes
to help us and the community
thank you
and uh yeah another question
is asking is there a plan to make common
voice have more natural conversational
or spoken speech instead of reading
speech
i think naturally as the data sets
continue to grow in senses as we collect
become more and more diverse that'll
just naturally occur over time but i
don't think there's a direct focus on
uh engaging with like strictly uh more
conversational speech verbs
sentences that we pull from wikipedia
for example
we still have a few more minutes left so
if you have another any other questions
just click
post those in the comments
all right uh we
uh have no more questions uh thanks a
lot gabriel uh for the
great talk
and uh thank you all for uh joining
joining this talk and uh i'll see you up
in half an hour for the for the next
talk so good day or good evening thank
you thanks for having me and uh hope
everybody enjoyed the talk and hope to
see you guys on the discourse and uh
engaging with the platform have a great
day
thank you